all right congrats in season four guys
thank you how's that feel season four
good it was a big one yeah we're excited
to kind of share it now yeah very
excited thing there's a lot good stuff
in there I think the stories really
opened up a lot changed a lot I think
there's gonna be a lot and therefore for
all of our phones think that would enjoy
yeah so what are you most excited for
fans to see in this season in this
season's really way you see the kind of
true Roger and Briana they change a lot
from season two to season four and this
is really where they sort of come into
their own and I think they can both be
quite guarded characters at time but at
times but I think in this season you
really do start to see far more aspects
of their personality and they're both
very much put through the ringer and
it's interesting to see how they deal
with us I think for us it's just - yeah
for the funds to be able to see the kind
of the Roger and Bri that book funds
have sort of come to love yeah should be
great
no I wonder this seems I most enjoyed
was you serenading her what was that
like I mean I think I read that you you
are a singer and were you nervous at all
or was there any sort of just going I'm
not sure I was nervous as such not for
that no not with the singing on the
guitar playing Pepsi there was one song
that was quite Shrek II because it was
actually it was actually originally a
federal track which had been redone for
the guitar and I drove everyone mad came
from sitting on that stool and a killer
well yeah Scott yeah you have to be
quite can set it up to the to the year
to the crew and to the rest of the cast
when you then you you know ticket plate
when you pouch up on a stool with a kilt
on but no I really really enjoyed that
the singing in the guitar plan that was
good fun it's it's SAT - Roger that you
may not have necessarily seen on all the
fans are quite aware of him in terms of
and being a musician and whatnot and but
it was nice to play just a different
aspect of the character which i think is
quite which I think it's quite addictive
season for generally for our characters
as you start to see a lot for new say to
these characters that you maybe haven't
really seen they start to kind of come
into their own and you start
I suppose them and their one world yeah
and I go to places within themselves
that you didn't really know that Roger
and Bri had the capacity if you like to
go to I mean they really do change from
the beginning to the end don't thing but
I mean the guitar playing is beautiful
if if I was serenaded with that song it
would definitely work so ya know
nice well played that's a good review so
obviously a lot of your scenes are just
the two of you so far that we've seen I
mean what does that been like just
primarily working with two of you how
does your relationship sort of grown in
that sense I think so if they're now in
terms of how we walk together I think
our ideas of Roger and Leon are very
similar if not the same I think the
story that we want to tell with those
characters this is very much on the same
page we have a lot of ideas together I
mean we'll chat a lot about the
relationships or what I think well I
feel quite lucky that I'm walking with
an act of it you have you can have that
dialogue with and you can [ __ ] it where
you want to call with it and we're
always looking for I didn't always the
development of develop those characters
in the relationship and a very honest
can of truthful way and I feel like a
lot doing now mmm-hmm yeah um so
obviously Outlander is known for having
some very devoted fans I mean I'd say
some of the best fans do you have any
really fun or not crazy but just wacky
fan stories or interactions we actually
had a really sweet one this weekend
there was some funds sort of waiting
outside of our hotel and one of them
really really nice lady had a friend's
hoodie on and I was like all my goodness
I really like your hoodie and then we'd
actually gone we were out for the
evening we'd gone to a game and we came
back and it was it was sort of like
10:00 p.m. so it's a fair few hours
later and they were still outside and
she'd gone and bought a hoodie
she had bought me nothing you know
things could be so low but there was
just really was really touched I felt I
didn't I felt awful that sort of taking
it but it was you know what's really but
they're so supportive and so they're
always paying attention and
there's such a passionate loyal fanbase
and you know women they're always there
for us and if we'd like to drop little
things in and of you or see something
and they pack up on it like for example
when we're in Savannah this woman came
running up to me with a bottle of
marshmallow fluff because I'd said it
like that like a couple of days prior
these things like that they're always
there and they're always kind of trying
to look after us and make sure we're all
key and love comes from our friends and
it's it's amazing and I ass I think we
have a really good time whenever we
interact or have any sort of exchange
for the fans are always good fun oh all
right well thank you so much guys really
appreciate it